what is the value of completing an MBA
since I graduated from the insert MBA in
2016 I got asked this question a lot
from family and friends on my Instagram
channel firm learning in the last days
also posted several pieces on my
learning journey my reflection on what I
took away from the MBA and there as well
I received lots of questions on whether
it's actually worth it to complete an
MBA in these times in this video I'm
covering the top five reasons why I
believe the MBA might make sense for you
so I hope this helps you to evaluate for
yourself whether doing an MBA might be
worth your time and your money hi there
my name is hi analyst and welcome to
another coffee break with firm learning
if you are already a subscriber I'm so
grateful that you're following here on
this YouTube journey and if you're not a
subscriber yet if you take any value out
of this video please consider
subscribing and also hitting the like
button for the YouTube algorithm so what
is an MBA program so for those of you
who don't know just let me give you my
brief personal definition of it
the MBA stands for Master in Business
Administration it is an academic degree
but the big difference compared to many
other master programs that exist in
business especially in Europe is that it
is a post experience program this means
that you're usually only able to get
into the program if you have several
years of work experience so typical MBA
program would have an average work
experience of that class of four years
so the average person attends an MBA
will have four years of work experience
and usually the bare minimum that you
need to have is two years of work
experience and this is often also only
possible if you come from a so-called
accelerated career environment which is
typically considered either consulting
or banking but you're assumed to just
have collected lots of experience in two
years so most of the time if you come
from a more regular industry background
you will be expected to have at least
the full four years of experience before
you can enter the program and the second
key difference to the more traditional
business oriented master programs as
exist especially in Europe is that why
these master programs are usually more
focused on preparing you for an academic
career the MBA is more professional
degree that is supposed to help you
prepare to become a manager in the real
if you want to put it this way right so
really to prepare you to succeed in a
business environment and not in a
specialist role but more in a general
management role and so before I talk
about the reasons why I believe that
codes make sense for you to do an MBA
let me cover the top two reasons why you
maybe should not do an MBA and these two
reasons come down to the investment that
you need to make when doing an MBA and
this investment consists of both time
and money so if you look at the time
aspect of things an MBA program usually
takes either one or two years with some
programs in the middle and what you will
typically see is that the u.s. programs
are on the longer side of the spectrum
so rather on the two-year side of things
whereas the European or international
programs are more on the one-year side
of things but of course there are some
deviations from that rule in both
directions and of course you need to
realize that one to two years are a
significant time investment instead of
doing the MBA you could work on your
career in the job that you're currently
having and also advance in this job in
this one to two years of time and you
need to be convinced that by doing an
MBA you can actually accelerate your
career so much that this loss of time
will actually be recovered later down
the path and the second element of it is
the cost if you currently look into how
expensive an inside MBA is this is the
program that I competed it currently
costs above eighty five thousand euro
for the one year MBA experience so I was
lucky that when I completed it I believe
it only was sixty-five thousand euros so
you can see that the cost of these
programs rather tend to go up over time
and I also had the privilege to get some
funding from my employer at that time
but many other didn't I needed to pay
the full amount when you pay for such a
program you need to consider that not
only you lose the money but usually in
this time period of the MBA in this one
or two years you also cannot work so
you're losing the celery the income for
this time period as well so it's kind of
a double cost because you need to pay
for it on the one side and then also
lose the celery of it on the other side
so doing an MBA can be quite expensive
and again you need to believe that then
later down the road you will recover the
cost due to an accelerated career
development and a higher salary that
you're
which you wouldn't have God if you
wouldn't have done the MBA so is there
any basis to believe that you actually
can recover this investment where there
are many rankings of MBA programs out
there one of the probably most renowned
is the Financial Times MBA ranking and
in the current 2020 addition you see
Harvard Business School on one wharton
of the university of pennsylvania or
number two the Graduate School of
Business from Stanford on three and the
NCR program on number four in the global
ranking and in these rankings you
typically see how salaries and other
kpi's of the alumni of these programs
developed so if you know look into the
Harvard figures the program ranked
number one you see that the average
salary of the alumni corrected for
purchase power parity so the weighted
version lies around two hundred ten
thousand US dollars and this is supposed
to correspond to an increase compared to
the pre-mba salaries of 110 percent just
for your information in this financial
time ranking this is measured by looking
into the salaries of the alumni three
years after completing the program for
the insert MBA the numbers are bit lower
on average alumnus would year the celery
of one hundred eighty one thousand US
dollars three years after graduation
which would correspond to an salary
increase of one hundred and one percent
compared to the pre-mba salary of course
now the Harvard MBA is two years while
the NCR MBA is one year so the return on
your investment in time is even higher
now for the insert one so looking at
this yes there seem to be some
plausibility that after doing these kind
of programs your celery can get boosted
to a level high enough that it actually
justifies the time and the money that
you invest upfront but be aware that
this is only a spectrum so while it
might be worthwhile for many people
there will still be a certain group of
people doing this MBA for whom it didn't
really work out as they hoped and of
course these are some of the most
renowned some of the flagship MBA
programs out there there are many many
other MBA programs which have kpi's that
fall short and of course you need to be
aware that these programs are some of
the globally leading ones and it's not
guaranteed that you get admitted to them
you need to show a certain level of
professional and academic performance in
order to get admitted so you might be
stuck with one of the lower tier
programs and
stats of these programs usually are not
as good but then on the other hand side
often the cost dollars and others high
so now we talked about two more obvious
things time and money and why this is
super relevant and probably most people
already think about if they ask
themselves whether they want to do an
MBA in this video I'd like to cover five
reasons five advantages that I got from
doing an MBA which I believe are less
obvious I may be less clear to many of
you who think about doing that so I'd
like to cover this in this video now and
of course now I forgot one of the
biggest advantages of doing an MBA and
this is that you're going to get all
kinds of great and crazy shirts I mean
look at this amazing spot shirt of the
NC MBA this is what you will get this
way doesn't matter where you do it but
now jokes aside back to the video so
let's start with number one and this is
looking at the MBA as some kind of Joker
card that you have after the first years
of your career you might find yourself
already kind of stuck in a certain box
in the corporate world maybe you are an
accountant or your controller or you did
lots of marketing and sales and you're
afraid that if you just continue your
career the way you're currently doing it
you will be just so stuck into this
position then it will be really
difficult for you at some point to
transition into a completely new role so
one of the reasons that people do an MBA
for an I found out from looking into my
peers in the MBA that this works really
well is to make a bold transition into a
new role and if you think about it
conceptually most people think of doing
these kind of transitions in three
dimensions you can either transition to
a new geography or you can transition
into a new industry or you can
transition into a new function so
regarding geography maybe you currently
work in Europe and you'd like to make
the transition to work in Asia on the US
so doing an MBA can help you with that
all you would like to change industry
maybe you've worked a lot in automotive
and now you'd like to work for retail or
for healthcare again doing an MBA can be
helpful to you or you'd like to change
functions so currently you worked a
managerial accounting or you worked in
production or you worked in marketing
and sales and you'd like to switch to
another function so doesn't matter which
of these three dimensions you would like
to change the NBA is like a Joker card
that you can pull out once in your
career
and it can help you to make this
transition because on the NBA you get
exposure to all these new sectors all
these new fields or roads you can take
new courses that are relevant to the new
row that you'd like to take and all of
this will help you transition into your
new field the only thing that many
people will give you as an advice is to
not try to change all these three
dimensions at the same time so do not
try to change the geography the industry
and the function at the same time if
you're looking to do a transition after
the NBA but try to keep at least one of
these three dimensions constant and try
to only change two of them because
experience shows that otherwise you
would have quite some difficulties and
the change is just too much but of
course if this is what you really want
to do there's always a way to make these
things happen if this is what you're
really after so the second reason is
regarding the type of content that you
learn and what is this think tough about
MBAs is that because they do not have so
much an academic focus they can focus
much more on teaching you practical
skills that you will not find in typical
other university programs so as I am
someone who has already studied business
in an undergraduate level so the
business degree from the University of
Munich and then I even have a master
degree in finance from the London School
of Economics so even for people who
already have business exposure in the
university fields it is true that if you
do an MBA there will be some repetition
because the MBA program does not assume
that all the people already have a
business background so it teaches you
foundational courses which will be some
kind of repetition if you already have a
business degree but the truth is then
that later on there will be lots and
lots of courses which you will likely
not have had in your regular standard
university undergrad business degree so
to give you some examples it in say
there were courses offered on
negotiations so how do you negotiate and
we did lots of role plays with
professional negotiation coaches to
improve our negotiation skills we had a
course on corporate turnarounds so how
do you actually handle a company
situation where the companies into heavy
financial distress and you will need to
return around what are the implications
of that how do you behave in this kind
of context as a manager and of course
lots of courses on entrepreneurship on
building businesses on identifying new
business models and many other aspects
of that so this is really hands-on
experience that you will not get and
most other more academia focused master
or bachelor programs and this is what is
so special about the content that is
taught at an MBA the third reason for
doing an MBA is the network that you
build and this is a bit of a cliche
point there are people out there who
claim that getting and building a
network is one of the main reasons to do
an MBA so viola what necessarily agree
with that I agree that it is one of the
key advantages of doing it during your
MBA program you will have the
opportunity to build friendships and
deep relationships with so many of your
classmates and there will be friendships
coming out of it that really will last
your whole life and when you choose what
program is right for you I would
recommend you that you also have a look
what your griffon your program is
focusing on so if you for instance aim
to build a career for yourself in the
u.s. after your MBA it would likely make
lots of sense to also do an MBA program
which is in the u.s. because this will
then help you to build a deeper network
in the u.s. if for ever you'd like to
rather work in Asia probably doing an
MBA summer and that geography might make
more sense for you but more specially in
the inset MBA for me is that one of the
distinguishing factors of the NC MBA
experience is that it wants to be an
especially international program so
tries to really balance out the class
there's no one dominating culture no one
dominating geography in the class so you
will really have contacts from literally
all around the world after you complete
the program and this for me means now
pretty much doesn't matter which country
I want to visit or which country I might
work in in the future there will be some
people who I can call up and talk to
them afterwards and this of course is a
great feeling not only from the
professional perspective but also for my
private and personal life the fourth key
reason from my perspective to do an MBA
is the cultural awareness that you build
and again this depends a bit on what
program your true
about the profile of this programís but
inside was a highly international
program and just meeting all these
people from that many cultures really
had a big positive impact on my life
during my MBA I had the opportunity to
spend half the time in the French campus
but the other half also in the Singapore
campus so spend roughly half a year in
Asia in Singapore and it would be very
typical and I heard this a lot from
people doing other MBA programs as well
so this is not only specific to the NCR
program but it would be very typically
that almost every weekend there would be
all kinds of trips being organised by
people who were native of different
other countries to then visit this
country with a bunch of other NBA
friends so in the one year of my MBA
program I was in Israel I was in
Singapore of course I was in Vietnam I
was in Indonesia I was in Thailand I
spent two weeks with friends in India I
was in China I was in the US and this is
just a selection of all the countries
that I wasn't and to be honest before I
did the MBA as somebody who lived in
Europe Asia was a pretty far away place
for me I was there a couple of times 40
days but I really didn't have any clue
what Asia was all about but now after
I've spent half a year of my life in
Singapore after visited so many
countries there and have met so many
local people during the MBA program this
really opened up my mind and I have a
completely different relationship to the
continent and I could very well imagine
to live there to work there to spend my
time there
this really has helped me a lot to
better understand this whole continent
though of course it is clear that given
the diversity of cultures and countries
on that continent whatever I have
learned can only be a brief scratch off
the surface and the last key advantage
of doing an MBA that I like to share
with you is that it really is a time
where it helps you to self reflect on
yourself on your goals and on your
ambitions so while I was working at
McKinsey before the MBA there was really
little time to rest and while I learned
an insane amount of things were working
at McKinsey there was really little
downtime really little time that allowed
me to does introspect to self reflect
and to ask myself what the right move
me is now going forward and the NBA
really is a great time for that because
it's not only that you will often have a
bit more time for yourself than during
your regular work but also given the
fact that you have all these
inspirations from the courses that you
take from the peep and the study with
you from the countries that you visit
all of these inspirations really help
you to take a step back and ask yourself
what you really want what your
objectives are what you want to do in
the future and this again helps you to
make the right decisions for you what
you want to do after the MBA so guys I
was just out here on a run where I
remember even another reason even
another advantage of doing an MBA that I
forgot and this is that an MBA due to
just the crazy change of environment it
can really help you reset your habits
and what I mean by that just as an
example you know before the MBA when I
was working at McKinsey I really
struggled with sports doing sports
regularly oh really unfair so I'm really
struggled with sports but because of the
change of environment because of all the
new impressions that I had during the
NBA this really helped me to pick up a
regular running habit so I literally
went from not running at all to running
regularly and then shortly after the NBA
I did a full marathon so 42 meters for
me and truly this would have not had
happened if I wouldn't have done the NBA
and I won't just don't get the
environment all the side products and
this is also one of the effects for me
for sure that came out for me for the
NBA so take care all of you and enjoy
have a good day so these are my five
reasons but after reflecting all myself
is what I think I got out of the NBA
most so this is not to say that an MBA
makes sense for everyone so whether an
MBA is worthwhile for you depends on I
think lots of factors are outlined a few
also in the beginning regarding the time
investment and the money investment but
I hope this video helps you make these
deliberations for yourself and also hope
to have added a few more considerations
and reasons which maybe were not that
obvious for you when you were thinking
about doing an MBA so let me know in the
comments below do you
when you hold an MBA are you thinking
about doing an MBA what are your pros
and cons let's have a conversation there
I'm going to answer to every single
comment that you're right and if you
took any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
YouTube algorithm and of course
subscribe to this channel to learn even
more I'm going to release at least one
new video every Saturday and if you'd
like to see even more content for me
follow me on instagram under the handle
firm learning i'm posting new content
pretty much every day at the moment i
hope you like it
thank you very much for watching I very
much appreciate your time hope you're
all having a great weekend
stay safe and keep learning everybody
this is highly forum from learning bye
there